right
do you guys believe that sex is a duty
in a marriage
and that is part of submission so you
start
i don't see as a duty because as i was
saying earlier like putting the word
duty
is a sign in it like it's a job
and for me
in a relationship the sexual aspect is
natural and it happens and it flows and
if there is an issue there it should be
able to be resolved
um but i i don't know it depends on
who's looking at it to be honest well
but let's say you get married tomorrow
right you meet mr tall dark and handsome
boom you get your rang you're married
right you're you're gonna be married
hopefully right 50 years you don't think
there's times where you're not gonna
maybe the sex part will fizzle out just
realistically even if you're very
sexually attracted to him yeah so so
when that happens do you think it's a
duty
no because there's more to the
relationship than sex
so when you have a relationship there's
so many facets that build that
relationship for women yeah so so i'm
gonna i'm gonna ask guys
so so so i'm just curious would you
marry it would you marry uh yes you know
would you would you guys marry a girl if
sex was not on the table
no not whatsoever not at all no
i don't know i'm not saying sex is not
on a table if you're in a you know
you're married and it starts to fizzle
out that's what i was kind of talking
about
sex is important don't get twisted we're
all sexual and it's very important well
i think i think the issue is that a lot
of men get involved in sexless marriages
and i saw a stat that said over the age
of like 60 it's 50 percent or in sexless
marriages
and so it's like guys will get married
thinking that they that sex is part of
the deal
and then it fizzles out after the kid
after the woman gets the the resources
and the legacy that she wants okay and
so that's that's why i bring it back to
the question is when those times come
and you don't want to do it do you think
it's a duty and that's part of
submission is having sex when he wants
to
um
i guess so yeah because you want your
marriage to sustain so at some points
maybe you don't want to
but it is what it is like i don't know i
don't i don't i can't i can't see that
for myself so i don't
understand i think i think we need to
also separate what a duty is and what
submission is because i personally would
say that sex
is a part of your duty within our
marriage because marriage contains
upkeep
and upkeep is different from a man to a
woman men
you know are more active x y and z not
to say that women aren't because i know
plenty women are but that is more of a
requirement for a man than it is a woman
but to say that it falls into the into
the puzzle of submission i think that is
tailored to the type of woman or the
type of man that is in that relationship
i think sex is something that definitely
within a marriage
is a duty on both ends because
you like you might have a couple where
the woman is much more sexually active
or whatever it may be in comparison to
the man and it is it's something that
has to go both ways why because when
you're in a marriage you've decided to
commit and that commitment takes upkeep
when people say oh
if you think love is the only thing
that's gonna keep your marriage together
then you're then you have like a shock
it's that sort of maintenance and it's
required
what do you guys think
what i would say basically it's pretty
much a duty right the word might not
sound nice i mean it's a duty but i'll
say another word which is a priority
there's some key priorities in a
relationship one of those being like
respect love trust and sex is one of
those as well that don't get me wrong it
can come to a time where a woman doesn't
feel like it and so forth and if that's
the case then okay you can get away with
it here and there but if it starts to
grow into a prolonged period of time
where a man is not getting the cookies
over maybe three months or two months
even a month really that's like pretty
extreme unless there's some medical
things going on it's pretty much a duty
it's a priority to maintain a
relationship so it may not like the
sound of it but it's a duty just as it's
a man's duty to provide his sort of
masculine attributes towards the
relationships of providing and
protecting a woman does bring femininity
and part of that is sexuality
what do you think
um well initially
i was of the opinion that
while
in concept it could be considered a duty
it might not be at the same time
and the reason why i say that's because
the word i think duty kind of implies
that it's something that is owed to
somebody
and then that's where for me it kind of
gets a little bit into icky kind of
territory
but um at the same time hearing what the
others have said they might have changed
my mind a little bit
just because
you know as you were saying as you were
saying as well it is
part of a relationship and you have
committed
committed yourselves to each other
effectively for life because that's what
it is it's an oath to stay together and
so if one person wants sex and the other
one's like no what are you gonna do when
it gets to years down the road sort of
thing
so
i can definitely understand in that in
that regard but then what i would
probably replace the word duty with is
commitment
if just because it might sound a little
bit more pc
i don't know if that's the right thing
it just sounds a bit better but when you
say duty it kind of almost feels as if
if somebody was to you know say
no or somebody came up to you and said
you have to have sex with me it's your
duty just imagine being that person on
that receiving end you're just kind of
like oh
that's a bit
kind of well i think i mean i think the
point is it shouldn't get to that like
as women if you're truly submissive
like like the guy should get especially
if if he's bringing like his time
attention and resources to the table
like yeah like i'm sure cam newton is
paying all of the bills do you think
that man deserves sex on demand fair
fair
that is true it's true it's like if i've
even had discussions with my friend then
they'll be like oh
[Music]
you know um
if you're um let's say in a in a
situation where you're you're you're
going out and then they pay all like
let's say hypothetical
date
you're going out oh i've gone out i'm on
a date they've paid for all the food and
all the you know all the building stuff
and now we're gonna go
um
home and you know oh i'm not gonna give
him sex not necessarily like it has to
be at that point in time but just
imagine like
and i'm just saying like
once you accepted his money you kind of
sealed that position of owing him
something not like you it happens a lot
bro
no no not like i'm not saying that it's
something that you should give up freely
but i'm saying once you ex start
accepting stuff and taking from a person
because what girls are taking this what
girls investment in you what girls do is
they they go on dates with guys they're
only half attracted to or kind of
attracted to and and they waste that
man's time attention and resources
whether it's conscious or unconscious
because if a girl is really attracted to
you it's going to be incredibly hard for
her to sit like to
to not have sex and that's like because
but a lot of times girls will go on
dates or like foodie calls
but i wanna i also just wanna touch on
the reason why i said i disagree is
because i feel like when you're dating
someone nothing is obligated we can go
on a date and i can pay for the whole
meal and do you know what i mean oh
absolutely absolutely when you're in a
relationship that's when the rules
change no no you're 100 correct i was
just kind of trying to use it as an
example as the idea of explain accepting
something from someone you're kind of
allowing them to invest in you right and
then to just cut them off it's kind of
deep yeah yeah so imagine
it being a full-blown marriage and
you're like nope
what i'm saying
yeah so this is why it's important that
if when you get into a relationship that
a lot of this is laid out on the table
because you can't have
like
all these expectations in your head and
not voice them and then when something
happens or like for example if if a man
expects regular sex he needs to voice
that to his woman and vice versa because
if they now have a disagreement and you
know as a man that her retaliation is to
withhold sex
you can't not come and be mad at her
because you haven't expressed that that
is a requirement for you
so like this is also another thing that
communication is very very key when
you're going to get into a relationship
or a marriage or whatever you need to
list what is required i would agree with
you yeah but i would say this though
there's a synergy between masculinity
and femininity they work together well
even sexual that sexual attraction when
two people really fancy each other on a
carnal level it's very hard for them to
withhold sex from each other so if
you've got to that point where she's
lost that for you or maybe you've lost
that for her maybe that relationship is
coming to an end so as i say like it
shouldn't go a long prolonged period of
time but um it is pretty much a duty
even though the word might not sound
right to some of them it is what it is
bro yeah can i just quickly add i was
going to say just to add to miriam's
point yeah
sex is a form of appreciation to a lot
of men and when you don't show
appreciation yeah
you're you're teetering on on a fin
you're teaching on thin ice
in a relationship if there's women ready
to throw sex at your man and you're not
you're withholding sex then
for
me in that respect you're you're pushing
him away do you get what i mean so for
me it's a
a way to show appreciation
actually that was